[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
so I'm sure by this stage most of you
guys have heard of Google duplex I was
actually in Bulgaria when the news break
about this so I quickly had to make my
way back to Australia to make this video
so if I'm out of breath
that's why okay so in this video we'll
take a deeper look at Google duplex so
what is duplex
it's basically an extension of Google
assistant that can make phone calls to
real humans just by you asking it to do
so it's a deep neural network that
builds off wavenet technology wavenet is
a speech synthesis program that worked
by joining very short units of sound
together to create speech it was a
breakthrough in natural speech synthesis
when it came out we've already taken a
look at it in a previous video but
here's a quick recap of what it can do
aspects of the sublime in English poetry
and painting 1770 to 1850 aspects of the
sublime in English poetry and painting
1770 to 1850 this is what happens when
you don't type in anything for wavenet
to say it's still generating raw audio
to randomly imitate human sounds and it
still sounds like words Belon boo he as
the head Sheen we've gained two feet so
it was a pack did I just tied fiction
toe Cerreta to silent yoga with a
shavette study could as well duplex is
another neural network built on top of
wavenet the final result is an AI that
can have realistic conversation but with
wavenet vocal precision and here's the
grand unveiling of two Plex at Google's
i/o event in May of 2018 but even in the
u.s. 60% of small businesses don't have
an online booking system set up so what
you're going to hear is the Google
assistant actually calling a real salon
to schedule the appointment for you
let's listen
[Music]
hi I'm catcher our clients I'm looking
for something on May 3rd don't give me
one mm-hmm poor what time are you
looking for well at 12:00 p.m.
okay we have a 10 o'clock 10:00 a.m. is
fine
perfect so I will see you inside 10
o'clock on May 3rd
ok 3 thanks have a great day bye no mayo
you hi I'd like to reserve a table for
Wednesday the 7th for seven people
it's for four people four people win
Wednesday at 6 p.m.
Oh actually really sir for like opera
like apply people for you for before you
can come how long is the way usually to
be seated
when tomorrow we care for next Wednesday
the 7th oh no it's not too easy it you
can conquer everyone okay
oh I got you Thanks
but the assistant understands the
context to nuance it new tasks for rate
times in this case and handle the
interaction gracefully according to
Google's blog the arms and asked the
ehia are put in sometimes synthetically
but actually it sometimes is there to
signal that the system is still
processing just like a human would the
public reaction to this was on the side
of shock and horror and even anger by
some some people thought that it was
very deceitful to have an AI talk to
someone over the phone without them
knowing but Google has made it very
clear that they're going to be
transparent they'll be letting the
people on the other end of the phone
know that they're talking to duplex
duplex has been trained in the narrow
field or scheduling appointments or
bookings and inquiring about a
business's opening hours on holidays to
be clear duplex cannot have general
conversations but I have little doubt
that the scope of widen in the coming
years
Google stated that there were unique
challenges when it came to training such
a neural net how do you get an AI to
robustly understand natural language and
reply in a realistic manner this would
be pretty hard to do
for example people tend to talk
differently to one another than with
computers we talk faster correct
ourselves mid conversation and even am
it parts of conversation and rely on
context instead throw in the poor
quality and noisiness of a phone line
and he have a pretty hard challenge on
your hands to solidify this points a
little bit let's think about the phrase
okay for for it's such a simple sentence
but it relies on many previous sentences
for context this phrase could refer to a
time or an amount of people we as humans
take such things for granted but it's
interesting to take a brand-new look at
this through the eyes of an AI or a team
of researchers trying to solve this
problem they came so how does duplex
work duplex uses something called a
recurrent neural network
if you don't know what a neural network
is it's basically a massive matrix
multiplication function where each part
of the matrix is built up of artificial
neurons called nodes the nodes contain a
mathematical formula and are arranged in
layers and each node has an input and an
output after receiving the inputs
whatever they may be the end goal of the
whole entire matrix or neural network is
basically to find out how to reduce how
long it is or in other words reduce the
amount of error perhaps the strangest
thing about neural networks is that no
one actually knows how they come to
their conclusion you just give them the
inputs and they somehow get an answer
your networks have been around for a
while in fact Ted Hoff the guy who
helped create the very first CPU at
Intel back in 1971 actually worked on
neural networks in his early career but
practical neural networks have only been
possible in the past five years or so
since about 2012 the general complexity
of neural networks has advanced 500
times and I think it's one of the most
fascinating fields of computer science
if you want a more detailed explanation
of how neural networks work there's an
absolutely brilliant video by the
YouTube channel three blue one brown
it's a remarkable explanation I'll leave
a link in the description below but
anyway I'm getting sidetracked so the
specific type of neural network that
duplexes using as I mentioned is called
a recurrent neural network these type of
networks have a small internal memory
that allows them to remember specific
inputs to help understand context for
this reason is pretty much the perfect
neural network for speech recognition
and set the heart of most speech
recognition algorithms so as I mentioned
earlier duplex was trained on a whole
bunch of different phone conversations
but how did it learn to understand what
was going on well the conversations of
course start an analog speech and then
this speech in audio form is fed into
Google's automatic speech recognition
system from this point on this audio is
now understood as text and this text
once converted into a format of the
neural network can understand is then
fed into the system other metadata and
other wider context information from the
calls such as the correct time for the
appointment schedule in question all the
time of day is also fed into the system
so tying it all together when the neural
network listens to a whole bunch of
phone recordings as inputs it eventually
learns how to reduce the amount
of error it has meaning that it has
better responses when spoken to
the final train neural network that
comes out of all of this is Google
duplex all right can I help you hello
hello what's up man hey um I wanted to
know what are your hours for today
10:00 a.m. to 6:30 p.m. okay got it
thank you for your time no problem sir
so what come to plex do in addition to
what was shown in the Google demo duplex
can also do some pretty interesting
things such as handle interruptions two
two three two two three okay elaborate
hi I would like to serve the tables from
May 25th so a would be for Friday and
May 25th and respond to audio issues
over the phone are you here yeah so
there was a lot of talk about this AI
passing the Turing test so for those of
you that don't know the Turing test was
a thought experiment brought up by Alan
Turing one of the fathers of computer
science back in 1950 he proposed a test
that goes as follows a person would
interact with a machine that they
couldn't see over text this individual
doesn't know if they're talking to
another person or a machine if the
machine can interact with this
individual without them suspecting that
they're talking to a computer then that
machine passes the Turing test Alan
Turing made the prediction that by the
year 2000 we would have machines that
would be able to pass the test and he
wasn't that far off the first machine to
pass the test was a text-based chat bot
in 2014 the Turing test was originally
just for text and Google duplex seems to
have passed the Turing test in the very
narrow field of conversation when it
comes to making appointments but through
voice not just text a bit that's
definitely something that a lot of
leading computer scientists didn't see
happening just yet
so I found that very interesting on that
point so some final thoughts
some people may think that this may take
jobs away from telemarketers and other
phone based work in the future this may
very well be possible but I'd just be
being reactionary if I was to say that
this was a certainty or if I was to say
that this will be a net negative on
society in any way because at this point
it's far too early to tell conclusively
a reminder duplex isn't for general
conversation is only specifically for
booking reservations and inquiring about
open hours during holidays but I'm sure
its scope is going to grow as far as the
assistant goes due to its limited scope
it doesn't really change how we live our
lives unless you have a disability I'd
say if a store has an online page it's
far quicker just to book that way but
then again duplex is using a neural
network and time and time again on this
channel we've seen how those things can
surprise us the scope may just grow
quicker than we think
but on a wider night this technology is
pretty cool it's becoming clear that
we're at an inflection point when it
comes to AI in the past couple of years
we've been marveling at AI breakthroughs
like alphago and others but now it seems
like we're starting seeing real-world
applications of AI coming into view each
time and making all this once thought
impossible possible a thing this will
start to get more and more commonplace
as breakthroughs keep occurring in
parallel so am I worried about duplex
not at all really I don't see anything
that should make me Google has stated
that they're going to be transparent
when you're talking to a duplex ai but
if this technology becomes commonplace
ask me that question again but I think
all in all society has to accept that
we're at the doorstep of a brand-new era
a time with unimaginable possibilities
and I think that's a bit of a privilege
as it stands right now anyway that just
about wraps up this video thanks for
watching this has been - go go you've
been watching cold fusion feel free to
subscribe if you just stumbled across
this channel and I want to thank all of
you guys that came to the debye
blockchain summer it was really cool
meeting some of you guys anyway that's
it I'll catch you again soon for the
next year cheers guys have a good
[Music]